SPEAKER 1: Today I'm really
delighted to introduce
Oliver Uberti and Dr.
James Cheshire, who've
written this magnificent book,
very beautiful and informative.
Oliver's a designer
and journalist.
He was previously
senior design editor
at "National Geographic."
And Dr. Cheshire is at
University College London,
where he's a senior lecturer in
quantitative human geography,
and has a great interest
in using big data
and visualization in
the social sciences.
So, please welcome.
Thank you.
OLIVER UBERTI: Hello, and
also hello to the wider Google
audience.
It brings me great pleasure to
be here, in a number of ways,
especially being here in Boston,
because my brother, Justin
Uberti, actually worked here
for at least a year, I believe.
He worked at the Kirkland
office and then came to Boston
and is now back in Kirkland.
He may be watching
so, what's up, bro?
We're going to talk about
a number of things today.
We're going to be talking
about data visualization.
We're also going be talking
about the partnership
that James and I
have, as an academic
and as a graphic designer
working on equal footing
to bring hard science to the
public in these immersive data
visualizations.
And we're going to
reveal how we do
that-- a bit of our process,
on the back-end processing
data but then also all the
labeling and front-end work
that goes to making
these data sets
more accessible to
the public than you
might find in the back
of a scientific journal.
But first I want to talk
a little bit about how
we came to know each other.
And that starts off with my
work in "National Geographic."
As a senior design editor,
I kind of came of age
as data and big data was coming
of age in the early 2000s,
and found myself-- even though
I was in the design department--
eavesdropping a lot in
the graphics department.
I was really
interested in this idea
of how we take
data and statistics
and start to visualize them.
And coming from a
fine arts background,
I like to work with
my hands a lot.
And we had this data
set from a story out
of the EPA and a study through
Baylor University, where
they were finding
pharmaceuticals--
evidence of
pharmaceuticals showing up
in fish tissue in sites
all around the country.
And to communicate
this, I thought,
we got to make a
fish out of pills.
And not
computer-generated pills,
not sugar pills, but
the actual medications
that were found in the study.
So we set up a photo studio
in a pharmacy after hours
and I created this large
mouth bass out of Prozac
and antihistamines.
The green and the yellow
pills are the Prozacs.
And it was really--
I had no way of knowing what,
really, pills the pharmacy
was going to have in stock.
So I showed up with this
spreadsheet of permutations
of how to keep the
ratios in balance,
depending on how many
pills were available.
And then I got word of a set of
research coming out of London.
And James' PhD
project was actually
looking at surnames and
the most popular surnames--
a huge database of
surnames in the UK.
And I was wondering
if he could help
me create a map of the most
popular surnames in the United
States.
And going back and forth
over a course of months,
we produced this map,
which reveals the 25 most
popular surnames in each
state, their size by frequency,
and color by country of
origin, approximately.
So you get pockets of
Scandinavian and German
ancestry in the Midwest,
Spanish surnames rising up
in the southern states, pockets
of French down in Louisiana,
and then, of course, up
here in Massachusetts
there's some Irish ancestry
poking in the top 25.
And to talk a little bit
more about this research
and what led us on to
our next collaboration,
I'll bring James up.
JAMES CHESHIRE: Hi, everyone.
Thanks for having us.
So, essentially, Oliver
was the first designer
I'd ever met, or even spoken
to, I think, at this point.
Traditionally, us in
the academic sphere
don't often stick our heads
out of our research offices
to speak to a broader audience.
And I really enjoyed working on
this particular project, where
we were taking kind of a
large database of names
and making them kind of
easily accessible and readable
this way.
And for someone who was just
a PhD student at the time,
getting something in the
"National Geographic" magazine
was kind of a big deal.
Alongside this, I was working
on lots of maps and graphics
about London.
So this was--
I'm not quite sure,
maybe a decade
ago now, maybe slightly less.
And London was really
entering a transition
from being quite a data-poor
city to a very data-rich one.
So there was a lot
of initiatives,
particularly in the
UK, but also over here
in the States about
opening up data,
making data freely
available to the public
and for others to
use and make use of.
And so this was bubbling away
in the background on a blog
that I was participating--
I was contributing to
and making new forms
of maps, that kind of thing.
And it gained a lot of interest.
And a couple of
publishers approached
me to turn it into a book.
And it occurred to me that--
you know, I'm good at making
maps that are OK online
and they look all right
in research papers.
But I really needed a
designer to take these maps
and put them on
the printed page.
And the options were,
you could submit a draft
manuscript to a publisher and
use their in-house designer.
Or you could work
collaboratively with one
as a co-author throughout.
And that's why I approached
Oliver as a recommendation--
someone to recommend,
really, in the UK.
But he'd just gone freelance
at that point and--
I think he thought I was a lot
further along with the project
than I actually was.
But he agreed to work with me.
So this was our first book,
called "London, the Information
Capital."
And we did a whole series of
dad visualizations on that.
This one is looking at 24 hours
of flights over UK airspace.
And just before we came out
with the book, Strava data,
the quantified self movement,
all that kind of stuff
had just started.
So we got access to a
bulk download from Strava.
It was still a startup, a
small startup at that point.
And we were able to map
the flows of cyclists
into London across
the rush hour period.
And so, I think, if
we look back and we
think about what the biggest
contribution of that book
was and is, it was this.
For the first time,
we were taking data
that were being
collected on apps
or that were already
collected and stored
behind firewalls and things
like that, we were taking it out
and we were taking it
to a wider audience.
And this was the first time
people had seen this stuff
about London, or even any city.
And so that kind of got us
thinking about some of the work
that we can do together
as a collaboration,
and how we can make
a contribution.
And we've decided that the
things we're really interested
in is taking a moment in
time when data is suddenly
becoming available in
unprecedented volumes,
capturing it in
data visualizations,
and publishing it as books.
And it's not just about data
visualization for its own sake.
We've all seen things
online where there's--
they kind of look
cool initially,
and then you look back at
them for a second again.
You think, actually, what
was telling us, or telling me
anything?
Or, I don't really
understand that.
Network diagrams
are a classic case--
social networks,
things like that.
So we're very much
in the business
of taking good
design principles,
good cartographic principles,
and transforming them
into compelling and interesting
data visualizations.
They look quite
traditional in many ways.
And you'll see that in some
of the slides we're showing.
So the London book
was a great success.
The publisher, obviously,
wanted us to do a second one.
And they were thinking about
UK, maybe another city,
something like that.
But Oliver, through his work
at "National Geographic,"
was keen that we move
spheres and actually move
into the animal kingdom, because
he'd noticed that they were
this kind of
technological moment
when millions or
billions of data points
were now being collected
on small sensors.
And for those-- if any of you
have worked with spatial data,
coordinates, that
kind of thing, you
know the great advantage
is the formats.
Everything is exactly
the same, whether it's
commuting cyclists in
London in this map,
or some commuting
baboons in this map.
And this is a study
where they had
GPS loggers on a
troop of baboons,
or most of a troop of
baboons, and they were
sampling them every second.
So they had their
location every second
over a three week period.
So that's a lot of data points.
And the nice thing about it was,
you get these daily movements.
So you can see, this is
where they start sleeping.
And then this is where
they go out foraging.
And then they loop back
to their sleeping site.
That gives a nice kind
of overall impression
of their behavior.
But what the researchers
were really interested in
is how baboons make decisions
on where they decide to go.
And so thanks to their
data, thanks to the fact
that they had data at
second-by-second resolution,
you can zoom in to
particular moments.
And the moment we chose
was the baboons running
across this area of crop land.
Here, they didn't like it.
They got harassed by
local herders and farmers.
So it was a big thing for
the baboons to run across.
They didn't want to hang around.
And we could then see
that exact moment.
We could see that some
baboons run off one way.
Some run another way.
And the fact that also--
the kind of "go" signal,
the one that they all
started running on, was led by
a juvenile and their mother,
not by an alpha male or female.
And you can see how at
different moments in time,
the baboons either
decide to compromise
where they want to
go or they choose
to follow one or the other.
But it's a fairly democratic
decision-making process
that the research
had a hunch about,
but were only
really able to prove
through a large-scale
data-mining exercise
to create these rules about,
when one baboon goes one way,
how do the others follow?
And this study
really represents,
I think, that transition
from a researcher
having to spend weeks in the
field in a hide or a truck,
just monitoring visually the
behaviors of these animals,
to essentially being able to
remotely follow them and things
like that.
And it's a transition
that, I think,
has probably been most profound
in looking at marine data
in particular.
So up until about--
I don't know, maybe 20
years ago, or even less,
probably 20 years
ago, was probably
one of most
comprehensive data sets
on the distribution of
whales that existed.
And it was actually created
from 19th century whaling logs.
So in this case, because
whales were a resource,
the city of Boston
in particular was--
all the areas around
here were particularly
dependent on whaling, you wanted
to know where the whales were
and how many you'd caught,
because it was essentially
an auditing exercise.
And a guy called Townsend went
through and manually mapped
each of the locations,
the approximate locations,
of where whales were
killed, by species.
And you get this
distribution map,
where you get different
species of whale,
at different times
of year, appearing.
And this, like a number of
examples in the animal kingdom,
is an example of where--
you're mapping where the
animals have died, essentially.
It's not when they're living,
but when they've been killed.
You're managing a resource.
You're not managing
a environment.
an ecosystem.
And that led
researchers in the 60s
onwards to start developing
their own mini-sensors
to monitor animal
movement and behavior.
So this is one of the
first bio-logging devices
that was created.
It was by a guy called
Rory Wilson, who was
at the University of Swansea.
And you can see here,
it's kind of a syringe
that he's pushed a spring in.
This is a piece of cork.
And on that piece of cork,
he had a bit of magnesium
that was burning when it
came into contact with water.
And they strapped it to
the front of penguins.
And when the penguin
was swimming, depending
on the speed it was going,
it would push that cork in,
kind of up that syringe.
And the magnesium would
burn a line on it.
And you'd see how fast
the animal was swimming.
No one had done this before.
And even with this
somewhat clumsy device
on the front of
them, he discovered
that the birds were
swimming faster and further
than we thought.
Jump forward to the present day.
This is what Rory's
lab now looks like.
It's kind of a mission
control for animal data.
Here we have a couple of minutes
of data from a circling vulture
that they've attached a tag to.
So you can see, there's all
kinds of different senses
that they've crammed into
this small device now--
accelerometers,
magnetometers, GPS.
And so this is like
a feed of information
they have about the
birds' spiraling behavior,
looking at turbulence over the
wings and that kind of thing.
So we really wanted to kind
of get to grips with the data
and see if we can visualize
it in an interesting way.
How do you take that,
which isn't necessarily
a user-friendly
version of a data feed,
how do you make that
into something that
looks a bit like this, where
you've actually just extracted
a small sample of that data, a
really interesting part of it,
just for a few seconds
of a vulture flight?
And you've looked at
the air temperature
outside, which is one of the
things that we're mapping here.
And you can really see how
the sensors are detecting
these really tiny kind of
fluctuations, perturbations
in bird behavior.
And they can start looking
and understanding that,
to see how the animal
behaves and how it
accounts for different things.
So that's the journey
we're on here.
And there's some really
remarkable technology.
So we've got Rory's really
high-resolution magnetometers,
accelerometers, and
things like that
that he's trying
to put on birds.
And then we've also
got tags that--
this is probably the largest
tag that we feature in the book.
It's about the size
of a computer mouse.
That thing is capable
of collecting something
like 62 gigabytes of
data in a 12-hour time
period about one whale.
And here there's a couple
of little attachments
where they stick suction cups,
the same thing you'd attach
a sat nav to a car window with.
They creep up behind the whale
with this thing on a long pole.
And then they kind of
just flick the pole down.
And it hits the back of
the whale and sticks on.
And then after about
12 hours it will
drop off and float to the
surface with all this data.
And these are passive sensors.
They have active ones too.
But they're passive in
the sense that they're
using the whale's sonar to
detect what the whale is doing.
So when whales-- toothed
whales in particular-- hunt,
they emit some sonar
that bounces back
from their environment.
And just as the whale is
detecting the bounce-back,
the sensors are able
to detect as well.
And we have the
exact moment-- this
is over a five-second period
when a toothed whale is
hunting a very small fish.
So this is a fish
that's maybe this big.
And just from the sonar--
it's a bit tricky to see here.
But you can see that there's
these signatures here.
And this is stuff
bouncing-- this
is the reflection coming
back from the particular fish
that he's after.
So the width of each
of these boxes--
columns here is the
time between buzzes.
So the whale starts
off clicking.
So it will let off a click
and wait some milliseconds
before the next one comes
back, a few milliseconds
before the next one comes back.
And it-- at kind of
a coarse resolution,
it realizes there's a fish here.
This is something
I'm interested in.
And then it zooms in
a bit on the fish.
And then for a
couple of seconds,
it then does this buzz, which is
a really high-resolution noise.
And then this is the signature.
And we get every
moment that the fish
is getting closer and closer.
The whale's head's here.
So this is kind of distant.
So you can see the fish is
getting closer to the whale.
And then this is--
at point C, this
is where the fish realizes
that it's possibly lunch.
And it coils up and kind
of springs off to try
and swim away.
So you get this slightly
more scattered impression
from the sonar here.
And then you get it swimming
off in this direction.
And then it
completely disappears,
because the good
news for the fish
is that the fish
essentially just did that.
And as soon as the
fish moves to one side,
the whale can't see it
anymore, because that sonar is
a pretty narrow field of view.
So the worst thing you can do if
you're being chased by a whale
is to try and out-swim it.
You just need to move to
one side, and it loses you.
So we have information about
how the whales are feeding,
about their particular ecology.
But we're also using animals
to do some ocean sensing
for ourselves.
So these are like animal
sentinels, if you like.
And this is one of our
favorite examples, really,
that shows some of the processes
that we're going through.
So this is a sensor--
it's actually quite large.
It's a little bit
bigger than this--
it's about this size,
actually, that gets
stuck to the head of a seal.
And it detects information about
ocean temperature, salinity,
that kind of thing--
not for ecologists,
but for oceanographers
who want to know what's going
on in the world's oceans.
And there's hundreds
of these seals swimming
around Antarctica.
And this is kind of
the raw feed of data
that comes back, or at
least some indication
of their location.
And this, to me, was
the first graphic--
raw graphic I produced.
And it really
captured everything
we were trying to
show for the book.
It was one of these graphics
that you think, wow,
that's a big hairball of data.
That's really interesting.
What surprised me, really, was
Oliver's initial take on it.
So here we have
the big hairball.
And I thought this would
be the main feature
story about these
particular sensors,
these particular animals.
I sent that previous
image to Oliver.
He then puts in a kind
of initial draft layout.
This is the first layout
that we came up with.
And you'll see that
his instinct is just
to remove all the color
and all that clutter,
and just focus on one individual
track, one individual story.
That's what we want to show
within this big hairball.
And it's a bit like this
in nature documentaries.
If you ever watch a
nature documentary,
they're not looking at the
whole colony of gannets.
They'll zoom in on one
particular breeding
pair or something like that.
It's because people can
understand that and relate
to it.
And this is essentially what
we're trying to do here.
So this is a fictitious track
that's just been drawn on.
But we start looking
through the hairball
to find one that we particularly
thought was representative.
And we settled on Rudolph,
who is an elephant seal that
was tagged for a year
or more-- actually,
I think, a couple of years.
And we actually track him
swimming along the Antarctic
Peninsula, hauling out
here on some sea ice,
and then swimming back across
towards the Falkland Islands
and around there.
One story, that we
then started thinking,
well, this is
really interesting.
But it's a bit of a
blank canvas still.
We've got the journey.
But what's he encountering?
What kind of terrain is there?
What's going on in
the water beneath him?
So we spent a lot of time
working on terrain-mapping
techniques-- and we'll
talk briefly about this
in a second--
that really captures the
ocean floor as it is.
So you can see the deep
trenches he's swimming over,
the sea ice he's encountering,
and really getting to grips
with that single narrative.
You'll see that we have
the hairball still, here.
But it's actually
been shrunk down
to quite a small part of
the double-page spread,
because we wanted to focus
in on that individual.
And what's more, we actually
gave Rudolph two spreads
in the book, which is quite a
privilege not many animals get,
two double-page spreads.
Because, actually, we were
interested too in the data
that he was able to collect
about ocean temperature.
So that particular transect is
strung across the page here.
The black line is the
depths that he's diving to.
Now, I thought this was
a glitch on the sensor.
But this line here
is 1,000 meters down.
So at that point, he breaks
1,000 meters underwater.
And I thought that
was a mistake.
But actually seals
are capable of--
they regularly dive to
those kinds of depths.
And that's why they're
great ocean monitors,
because as they're diving
down, they're collecting
all these measurements.
And you get a temperature
gradient here of data.
You can see how we've gone
from that initial hairball--
which looks a bit like this as
well, with the contextual data,
these individual animal types--
to a much cleaner impression
of what's going on.
So really, a lot of what we do
is a data-reduction exercise.
We talk about big data.
But we're actually
in the business
of reducing as much
of the data as we can,
to get insight or
intelligence, I guess.
For another part
of this story it
was really important to get
that contextual information.
So I mentioned the
sea floor that we
were interested in for Rudolph.
But if you're a bird
and you're flying,
actually that doesn't
make much difference.
What you're interested
in is the medium
that you're passing through.
And that's air, that's the
winds you're encountering.
So I'm sure many
of you have seen
this really excellent
weather visualization called
"earth.nullschool."
It was one of the
first visualizations,
as a cartographer, that really
made the cartographic community
sit up and think, actually,
computer scientists
know what they are
doing sometimes when
it comes to data visualization.
And they're capable of creating
these kinds of graphics.
So inspired by that,
I thought, we really
need to show global
wind patterns
for a story we've got
about albatrosses.
So here is something
I generated.
Does anyone use R here?
R-stats?
I did this in R.
It's probably one of my
proudest visualizations
I've ever done in R,
which captured the wind
conditions approximately
during the period
that we were interested in.
It's modeled data.
It's not actual-- they
have a few readings.
But of course, they
have to interpolate.
But you can basically
see Antarctica.
This is Antarctica, and
all the winds rushing off.
And the reason this
was so important
was it brought to life this
story about these migrating--
these wandering albatrosses
that go all the way
around Antarctica.
And in particular,
there's this point
of no return, which is these
Kerguelen Islands, here.
And essentially,
because of the way
that the winds are whipping
around the continent,
it's easier for a bird
to fly all the way around
than to try and turn back
to the breeding colony.
So you can see here, this guy
made it and then turned back,
whereas this one carried
on all the way around,
because they needed the
tailwinds to help them.
And the researchers
hadn't actually
mapped the wind onto their data,
or their data onto the wind.
So this was something that
we were quite pleased with,
because it really
brought to life some
of the importance of the context
that the animals are moving
through.
And that's often overlooked,
particularly by the researchers
who are more concerned about
the specifics of their data.
And then just a final example of
context that we can now do is--
thanks to satellite imagery
and remote sensor technology,
you can actually map the
data onto the conditions
that the animal was really
experiencing at that time.
So this is a story about
snowy owls in the Great Lakes
and how they spend time
over the winter and how,
thanks to tracking
technology, the researchers
noticed that the
birds were spending
a lot of time on lakes,
on the Great Lakes,
and actually discovered
that they were floating
on ice and hunting wildfowl.
And if we'd used a standard
satellite imagery base map
for this that was probably taken
in the summer or something like
that, all these blue circles,
which are moments when
the birds-- a partcular owl--
spent time drifting on ice,
would have been in water.
They wouldn't have been on ice.
So thanks to the NASA MODIS
imagery, we were able to get--
again, approximate date.
This was over a month-long
period we had this data.
So we selected one
day in that month
and we were able to line
up the bird information
with the actual ice information.
Often people overlook that.
But from a very
detailed perspective,
is quite important for
us to be able to do that.
And it's really
demonstrative of a transition
from a data-poor environment
to a very data-rich one
that satellites have
been able to give us.
So I'll hand over to Oliver now
to talk a bit more about some
of our design process.
OLIVER UBERTI: In
both of our books,
a theme that emerges to
us nearly every day--
we're working two years
at a time on the books--
that we could have never done
these books by ourselves.
I couldn't have produced this
book without James's ability
to process huge data sets
and his GIS expertise
and his just general knowledge
of cartography and computer
programming-- writing
custom scripts that
produced those wind patterns.
What I like to
bring to the table,
besides a journalistic
storytelling perspective,
is the design, the typography.
And a big part of helping a
reader engage with these maps
and pull away a
story is labeling.
And every time we
make a book, we
have to decide these
basic principles of,
what does a road
look like in our map?
How do we label a
country versus a bay
versus the actual animal's
behavior and tracks?
How do we create
a hierarchy that
lets the reader zero
in on what they want
to know as quickly as possible?
So I'm going to talk
you through one example.
I live in Los Angeles.
One of my favorite
stories in the book,
and the story of conservation
that feels most urgent to me,
is about P22 and the mountain
lions of Los Angeles.
I live near Griffith Park.
P22 is a bit of an A-lister
in Hollywood right now.
He's got his own
Twitter account.
You can get t-shirts with
his likeness on them.
This is an incredible
photograph by Steve Winter
He shot this for "National
Geographic" using camera traps.
And the problem that the
mountain lions in the Southern
California region are facing
is that they're effectively
marooned on genetic
islands by the freeways.
These freeways are 8,
10 lane lanes long.
In the Santa Monica
Mountains is one population.
P22 escaped out of
the Santa Monicas
and got to Griffith Park,
where he lives by himself.
But the chances of him getting
back to the Santa Monicas
to mate with another
female are slim.
And even then, he's still
mating within his own gene pool.
So the prognosis for his
genetics is not very good.
Down in the Santa
Ana Mountains--
south of LA towards
Orange County
on the way to San Diego--
is another population
of mountain lions.
And in both cases, they
really need an escape hatch.
They need a vegetated
bridge that--
you start to see in some other
countries, in Canada, Slovenia,
some countries are building
these forested overpasses
to allow the free
movement of wildlife.
There's a proposal that's been
green-lighted to help mountain
lions from P22's family up
in the Santa Monica Mountains
get across the 101.
But down in the Santa Anas that
proposal hasn't taken hold.
And so I really wanted to zero
in on that other Santa Ana
population.
This is about 15 years
of mountain lion tracking
in Southern California and
the Santa Ana mountains.
And as we showed with
the seals, if you just
plot the data that
comes out of the sensors
it doesn't mean a whole lot.
So how can we start
establishing context
to bring the story
to life for readers?
Well, one thing we want to do
is we want to lay in the terrain
that the mountain lions
are passing through.
So we've got digital elevation
models of the mountain ranges
along the coast.
And it was important to me
that this book come together
as an ensemble, and just have a
color palette and a visual feel
that tied all these
different maps or all
these different parts
of the world, all
these different species
and technologies together.
And again, coming from
a fine arts background,
I wanted to take these DEMs a
little bit further visually.
And there's a
technique you learn
in art school called stippling.
If you want to render an
object, the shadowed areas,
you can just draw a lot of dots.
And in the lighter, highlighted
areas, draw fewer dots.
So working together with James,
in a number of iterations,
he wrote a custom script
where he could essentially
take a digital elevation
model, run it through this,
and put lots of
little dots, a lot
of stippling in the dark
shadowed areas of the mountain
ranges, and fewer dots in
the lower-lying flat areas.
And so you end up
getting an output looking
like this, which we used
on every land-based map
throughout the book.
And that same technique
is what gives the texture
to the bathymetry you saw in
the seal map near Antarctica.
But then there's a lot
of human environments
that the mountain lions
are interacting with.
And we need to start
identifying them.
So this is me--
at the very beginning
of the book,
before we even start
producing a lot of these maps,
I'm coming up with a
typographic palette,
a series of three fonts that
we can use interchangeably to--
how do we label
the waters, how do
we label the cities,
a series of symbols
we can use to label
mortality events
or when a wolf kills an animal.
And then building a
template, an Illustrator that
has a hierarchy broken out.
So we can easily turn on and
turn off and organize all
of this contextual information.
And so then James starts
sending me exports.
This is drainage in
Southern California.
And most of this is--
all these green little streams
and temporary drainages
or seasonal drainages
are hugely irrelevant.
So it's an enormous
data-cleaning chore
to start turning this
into something that
doesn't make your eyes bleed.
Then you start throwing
in the road networks.
Now, this is really where the
story of the human environment
meets the story of
the animal behavior.
So this is going to be what I
want to highlight in my map,
more than the drainage.
And you can see, we've overlaid
this over the stippling.
And in our initial
drafts, you start
to get something like this.
And I've got all of the
data points you saw earlier.
And I've just grayed
them back, colored
them darker gray for male
lions and lighter gray
for female lions.
And then we started talking with
the researcher and thinking,
can we pull out five
individuals that
maybe show different behaviors?
For instance, the females don't
have a large dispersal range.
The female mountain
lions tend to stay
close to where they were born.
And they continue
to raise their cubs.
Whereas you get
mountain lions who--
the male mountain lions,
who need to disperse out
for a number of reasons, one
being that they will be killed
or eaten by the
older male mountain
lions if they don't strike out
and find their own territory.
So there's this one
intrepid mountain lion, M56,
who leaves the Santa
Anas near Camp Pendleton,
up here, and then comes down
along the coast in Oceanside
and cuts up along the Santa
Margarita River, and comes over
and is the only documented--
in 15 to 17 years--
mountain lion that's crossed
west to east across I-15.
So he gets across.
And you think he's home free.
He's got this unbroken chain
of wilderness, essentially all
the way down to Mexico.
But he comes down here into
the [INAUDIBLE] Valley,
preys on a rancher's sheep.
The farmer gets a
depredation permit.
And M56 was.
Shot The challenge is
not just getting across,
but getting across
and living long enough
to pass on your genes.
But again, this wasn't
really doing it for me.
The color scheme is
a bit lugubrious.
All the successive data points
in the background of the male
and female lions is really
making it harder to,
as a reader, connect with
the individual stories.
So I cleaned out all
of that other data
from all the other
lions and just zoomed in
and used bright highlight
colors to pull out
the individual stories
and, in the hierarchy,
subdued everything else.
Now this is an ongoing
conservation issue.
And it's a story of maybe
what we did wrong, right?
The mountain lions are a signal.
They tell us that maybe
we've gone too far,
that our freeways and
our infrastructure
is a greater barrier than
we had previously imagined.
And we need to now take steps,
like creating vegetated bridges
to step backward and give
the wildlife a chance
to live in proximity to humans.
But over in Kenya,
where the infrastructure
hasn't been so permanently
infixed on our landscape,
they're taking
proactive measures.
It's one of the first
places on the planet where
they're developing their
infrastructure with wildlife
in mind.
One of the great pleasures
of this book for me
was to go over to Kenya and
work with Save the Elephants.
And they allowed me to
join a collaring expedition
in Tsavo National Park, where
recently a major railway had
been built from Nairobi, in
the center of the country,
to Mombasa on the coast.
Now this railway--
high-speed railway
bisects Tsavo National
Park, right through elephant
migration corridors.
But, through Save the
Elephant's lobbying efforts
and working with a number
of local organizations,
they were able to get
the construction company
to install these
underpasses at points
throughout the entire railway.
It's an elevated
railway, and you've
got these tunnels underneath.
But what they didn't know was
which of these many underpasses
elephants were
most likely to use.
And if they could
figure out which
ones they were going
to use, then they
could target their conservation
efforts and anti-poaching
efforts to those corridors.
So we collared, while I was
there, 10 elephants-- five
male, five female.
They wear these big, bulky
belts around their neck
with a counterweight
on the bottom
and a GPS device on the top,
because the elephants are
pretty rough on these devices.
And they'll slam them
up against things.
They have to be pretty sturdy.
And then this is just a
zoom-in on a larger map
that we have in
the book, to show
what happened after 30
days of being collared.
And a key theme in this book is
that animals aren't these furry
robots out there in the world,
following a "Westworld"-type
loop.
They make individual
decisions all the time.
And a couple of those
individual decisions,
even within a species,
come out in this book.
So after being collared, there's
this one you see here in red.
She was collared up here,
off the top of the map.
And any time you have to
subdue an animal and collar it,
it's a little bit
traumatic for the animal.
They, incredibly, can shoot
a dart from a helicopter,
land, run over, take
all their measurements,
pour water on the animal, keep
its breathing airway open,
attach the collar,
and then inject
a antidote that wakes
the animal back up,
all within about
10 to 12 minutes.
I couldn't believe
I was watching
this right in front of me.
But after those 12 minutes,
the animal wakes up.
And Manyani here, the red
line, she comes rushing down
and goes right to the
humans that she trusts--
here, by the Kenya Wildlife
Service field training school--
and for about 30
days, just hung around
outside the ranger
school, because she
knew she was safe there.
A couple other ones just
continued doing what they do,
and going over to
some of the rivers
where they like to drink.
And this guy,
[? Rachinga, ?] down here,
he was the first
one, within 24 hours
of being collared, to use
one of the underpasses
and make his way up
here and back down.
And within a month he
was just crossing here
on a regular basis.
And here you get a
sense of both sides.
This is the railway
berm under construction
as we're flying in, and Tsavo
East over here and Tsavo West.
They're planning to
turn this two-lane road
into a multi-lane-- four-,
five-, six-lane road.
So this is going to be another
barrier for the elephants
to get across.
But again, with
proactive planning,
they can build
their infrastructure
with wildlife in mind.
This just gives you a
sense of how quickly
they can get in there
and collar the elephants.
And then the moment when
one of them wakes up.
Save the Elephants
wasn't too thrilled
that some rangers
spray-painted a number
on the side of the elephant.
But I guess that
makes it easier,
when they were doing
their aerial surveys,
to see where the ones
they collared were.
But anyway, that's one
of the hopeful stories
in the book of using this
combination of science,
research, technology, ecology,
and data visualization
to make sure that humans
and animals can coexist
moving forward.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 1: Any questions?
AUDIENCE: Did you often have to
deal with untrustworthy data?
JAMES CHESHIRE: What do
you mean by untrustworthy?
AUDIENCE: Like from--
different data sampled
from different places and
maybe you had to clean it up.
Or just that it just didn't
seem like it was actually
reasonable.
JAMES CHESHIRE: So it's an
interesting debate, actually,
within the community about
what you do with bad data,
because obviously-- there's
a bit of a trend or perceived
trend of academic life where
you have to be always reporting
positive results.
And sometimes negative
stuff is useful as well.
And this really applies to at
what stage you share your data.
So are you sharing data that
were collected-- the raw data
collected on the device?
Or do you share
stuff that's gone
through a data-cleaning process?
So we were getting data from
all stages of that process.
Now if some stuff
was completely off--
you know, GPS point was
1,000 kilometers away
or whatever-- then I did a basic
cleaning operation, which often
was a standard data reduction
thing, where you run across
and say, well, there's
no way an animal went
1,000 kilometers in an hour,
or something like that.
But our approach has always
been to try and show as much
of the data as possible
without doing too much with it.
Now, there's whole
studies on how
you interpolate between
data points and all
that kind of stuff.
But we try to stay out of that
as much as possible and just
show specific--
the raw data as best we can.
Because if a data set
has been interpolated
or if someone has done
some modeling on it,
then you've got to explain
that process as well
to the reader, which
we didn't want to do.
So the answer is yes, there
were messy data points.
But fewer than I
expected, actually,
given the technologies that
were involved, kind of thing.
AUDIENCE: Is there a dream
data set or dream data sets
that you haven't worked with
yet that you'd really like to?
JAMES CHESHIRE: We get
asked that question a lot--
OLIVER UBERTI:
Specific to wildlife--
JAMES CHESHIRE: But we're
no better at answering it.
OLIVER UBERTI: Or just
in general, on the next--
a future project?
AUDIENCE: You're the experts.
OLIVER UBERTI: OK.
JAMES CHESHIRE: Uh--
OLIVER UBERTI: We have a
third book in the works.
JAMES CHESHIRE: Which-- yeah.
OLIVER UBERTI: I just
don't know how much
we want to talk about it.
JAMES CHESHIRE:
No, there's stuff--
I think the dream--
so specific to this, the dream
that researchers are after
and that they're probably
a couple of years
away from getting
is interaction data.
OLIVER UBERTI: Yeah,
social behavior.
JAMES CHESHIRE: So we've got--
the example we have
is from some ants
that they put QR
codes on the backs of
and use high-resolution
cameras to track ants
in these particular colonies.
That was our largest
data set, because they
were getting interactions.
And they're planning-- there's a
group, particularly in Germany,
called the Max Planck
Institute for Ornithology that
are planning to deploy
enough sensors that you get
interaction both between animals
and predator-prey relationships
and human.
So as soon as you start
bringing interactions in,
the data set explodes.
And so that's something that
we're not quite at that stage
yet.
But that's something,
I think-- just
to get our heads around
that would be cool.
And then I think just
building on that--
Oliver might talk briefly.
But we're getting to the
point where animals--
they're backing
each other up now--
OLIVER UBERTI: Yeah.
JAMES CHESHIRE: With
their data as well.
OLIVER UBERTI: There's a story
out of Monterey Bay Aquarium.
We have a series of graphics
in here on the sea otters
off California,
and how they were
thought to be extinct
until a small population
was discovered back in
the 30s and protected.
And now they've rebounded.
And the Monterey Bay
Aquarium is doing
all sorts of
conservation efforts
and tracking to manage
that population.
And they're about to release,
if they haven't already
released it this
year, this program
called Otternet that I really
wanted to get into the book.
But the technology just
wasn't deployed yet
by the time we had to publish.
And Otternet is
that exact thing.
It's this idea of getting
the social behavior
and interactions between mating
males and resident females,
and how as an entire population
they're working together.
And between buoys, whenever
the otters pass by the buoys,
they offload their
data to storage.
And then when the otters
pass by each other,
they offload their data to
the sensors on each otter.
So in case anything
happens to the otter,
their data isn't lost forever.
That's really the frontier.
AUDIENCE: That was awesome.
Thanks for being here.
My question is, how much
do you know about the story
before you start the
visualization process?
Or do you look at a big
data set and figure out,
what's the right story
to tell based off this?
How much do you talk to
the researchers beforehand?
OLIVER UBERTI: The research--
this book is about animals.
But it's really about the
researchers who study them.
I mean, they were so kind
to sometimes welcome us
into their homes, in
Ohio or in Nairobi.
James went out in
the North Atlantic
with killer whale researchers.
They worked with
us start to finish.
We would usually do
initial interviews
to try and get a sense
of-- and maybe we'd
heard about their research
in a scientific journal.
And then we reached out
to them and told them
what we were doing.
And then we'd do initial
interviews to figure out, OK,
what could be cool to visualize?
What are some of your
favorite stories?
What are some of your favorite
individuals who have surprised
you with unique behaviors?
And then once they shared our
data, we'd do initial plots.
And it was always
a back and forth.
OK, are we on the right track?
Yes, this looks good.
And then at the end--
coming from "National
Geographic,"
my habit as a designer is
to build the visuals first.
And then we write the story
last to fill in the space
that the visuals have
allotted for the text.
And so once we had finished the
layout and drafted the story,
then we sent it back to them for
a final review and corrections.
JAMES CHESHIRE:
Yeah, I think there
was a slightly different-- that
was a difference in process
for the London book.
Most of that was in
my head to start with,
in the sense that I'd
researched the city.
I knew what was going on.
So I knew that these would be
the stories I wanted to tell.
Whereas this was
much more iterative.
It was like, oh, well--
you show the researcher
the graphic we've done.
And they were like, oh, well,
we didn't think of it like that.
Or, that's much
more interesting.
And you'd go back to
the drawing board, so--
OLIVER UBERTI: We have no
illusion that we're biologists.
We're not-- I mean,
geographer, designer.
But our combined
skill sets allow
us to help scientists share
their research more widely.
And also, in some
cases, we surprised them
with what we were able to reveal
about what their animals were
doing.
I just want to make one
more point to tack on that,
is that that is really--
for you here at Google and
people who work with data
and have these
incredible skills,
that's the beauty of this
animal tracking revolution,
is that you don't have to be
a biologist to get involved
in conservation.
These scientists all
over the planet--
they're inundated with data.
A week-long study
could inundate them
with millions of data points.
So they really need people
to help crunch the data
and interpret it.
AUDIENCE: Has either of
you specifically studied
cartography or worked
with any cartographers?
Obviously, "National
Geographic," for example,
has a huge cartography
department.
Or is it more just kind of
more general graphic design
principles that you work from?
JAMES CHESHIRE: So I've got no
formal cartographic training
at all.
So I did a geography degree
and then a geography PhD.
But none of it was
really cartography.
I think what's interesting--
I mean, the US is kind of
ahead of the UK in many ways.
There's a transition,
I think, that--
I teach cartography to students.
But I call it data
visualization,
because they get paid
five times as much
for it if they put that on
their CV, for one thing.
And secondly, there's
a lot more to it.
The good stuff about how
you convey information
to people and the
standardization of things,
and like that visual
hierarchy of labels
that Oliver was talking about,
I mean, that's really important.
But increasingly,
to make maps you
need to have this broader
data sciencey type
background, because that's
where the action is.
It's not where people--
people aren't having to
map new areas of the world
for the first time.
The frontiers, really,
are in these databases
that are being extracted.
So that's something I'm
really a kind of lobby
for within the
cartographic community,
back in the UK at
least, to try and get
more people with
programming experience
to learn a bit about cartography
and not make the same mistakes.
But also, people who have
got cartographic training
to learn a bit about
programming So they
can make the efficiency
savings like we've
been able to make in this.
OLIVER UBERTI: Absolutely.
By osmosis, working at "National
Geographic" for a decade,
I was immersed in their
cartographic practices,
labeling styles.
They have proprietary
fonts that they use.
But there are
things like, OK, you
can use italics for
physical features.
Or use different sizes of
sans serif or sitting labels.
And a lot of that was definitely
informing my thought process
when I set about to build
this typographic palette.
And we actually hired one
of my former colleagues
in the cartography department
to be a map editor.
So after we produced 50-some
maps he vetted all of them
and, in many, many cases,
spotted things that I never
would have picked up
on my own, such as--
I had a road crossing
the Niger River in Mali.
And in fact, there is
a ferry that takes you
across there, not a road, so.
SPEAKER 1: All right.
Well, thanks again.
Very nice.
OLIVER UBERTI: OK.
[APPLAUSE]